welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and doctor strange with multiverse
of madness just released a new trailer i
saw a tv spot during the super bowl with
what looked like zombie versions of
these characters what sounded like a
familiar bald hero of mine but now i
gotta watch him react to the youtube
version of this potentially some major
game changers here i'm gonna react give
my initial thoughts and then in a
separate video i'm gonna go through it
frame by frame to break down all the
minds that you might have missed making
new friends at a super bowl party be
damned i got work to do here we
go
every night
oh
it's just a thin layer of
whoa
a stairway to heaven or hell
what was that
what nightmare begins am i looking at
it's the old version of it we're gonna
see old people coming i did what i had
to do
that's enough that's enough trailer for
me to break down right there
you open the doorway between universes
thank you for doing that we'll walk
through it
what do you know about the multiverse it
has had his theories ooh she and vince
talked about it
your desecration
oh my god that's him holy [ __ ] it's
actually him and those chairs that has
to be the illuminati that's the
illuminati
holy [ __ ]
sinister strange
that's the house that's the one division
wesley house
that doesn't seem fair
it's not there
oh my god
this looks amazing is that zombie one i
i thought i saw zombie wanda in the in
that zombie strange
what if was real
what if is happening this is live action
what if
oh my god oh my god there's too much to
discuss there's too many implications of
everything
and where to begin
where to begin we gotta begin with
professor x charles xavier that was
totally the voice of patrick stewart i
don't know uh who they thought they were
full in there so
guys this is like willem dafoe and otto
octavia showing up in the no way home
trailer this is just the beginning if
patrick stewart is showing up in this
movie everybody's showing up in this
movie but what i am most fascinated now
to figure out is who is filling the rest
of those chairs because ladies and gents
that has to be marvel's illuminati now
if you don't know what the marvel
illuminati is it's not as uh terrifying
and like annoying as the real life
illuminati which doesn't exist or does
it marvel's illuminati is basically just
like the the u.n world security council
of the marvel universe or in this case
the marvel multiverse it really is the
uh the brightest minds the biggest
brains we actually saw a little easter
egg teasing the existence of the
illuminati on tony stark's smartphone
back in iron man 2. i think that was
just a throwaway joke because they
haven't referenced it since then here it
looks like we see either six or seven
chairs not all of them are filled and it
looks like they're all hooded it looks
like one of them is going to be patrick
stewart as charles xavier professor x
from the fox x-men franchise so many
things we can take away from this the
fact that they're acknowledging the
existence of that separate franchise is
now part of the mcu multiverse is
exactly the game plan from spider-man no
way home it means that all those
characters who existed in that
continuity are all part of the
multiverse that is connected to the mcu
as we've known it now does that mean
that every x-men character who is in
those movies is now going to be the main
x-men hero going forward in the mcu whoa
not so fast not so fast professor x
could just be a representative of a
universe that we're not really going to
visit going forward and certain select
individuals will make their way into
this reality so if he is on this
illuminati team who else can we expect
top of my list would be reed richards mr
fantastic are they gonna give us the fan
payoff of having john krasinski play him
are they gonna have ian griffith the guy
from the uh 2005-2007 movies do it
they're gonna have miles tyler do it
doubtful but i think if you're gonna do
an illuminati you gotta have him on the
team now the question is are we gonna
see an iron man tony stark variant
because marvel's illuminati tony stark
is a member of it is it gonna be robert
downey jr are those crazy fan wishes
that tom freaking cruz is gonna show up
here i think this is a great opportunity
to do that perhaps even a doctor strange
variant on this lineup uh in this
context it looks like they are forming a
supreme court style tribunal over the
multiverse doctor strange is in
violation of it they are a higher
judicial body than even the judicial
body we saw in the tva which i guess was
revealed to be a sham anyway a prop
government set up by kang but this is
like the real tribunal when you screw
with reality these are the guys you show
up to now if your shelves are feeling a
little bear and you could use some
support from the earth's mightiest
heroes our friends and whatnot are here
to help whatnot is a live video shopping
app where you can bid on cool marvel
collectibles right on your phone experts
go live on screen chatting with the
community and selling cool funko pops
action figures comics and maybe even an
infinity gauntlet or two on the whatnot
app like you can find some avengers
funko pops like uh oh i don't know
shawarma pose natasha romanov look how
tired she looks she just saved the city
she's earned a good knee lean whatnot
brings together a community of fans
built around the things you love hop
into a marvel auction and chat with
other fans meet knowledgeable collectors
maybe even discover an unexpected gym
and it's not just marvel memorabilia
there are options for pokemon sports
cards sneakers and all the cool stuff
that you just can't live without most
auctions start at just one dollar so you
can be sure to find a deal there's even
an occasional celebrity guest cameo and
some really fun giveaways so download
whatnot today using the link in this
video's description to get 10 off your
first purchase and yes maybe you'll even
find a slightly tired natasha ruminoff
too tired to even enjoy a bit of taziki
sauce that is right seems like the main
core thrust of this movie is putting
doctor strange on trial for all the
times that he has screwed with reality
or subverted timelines in some way like
looking forward at 14 605 different
outcomes in the future to help the
avengers find one path to victory to
undo thanos's snap that was one
violation what he did to help peter
parker recently the runes of kafka spell
resulting in this uh weird gaslighting
of society the logic of it not fully
explained but the only way it makes
sense is if reality is worked in very
specific ways you gotta imagine this
tribunal is pissed off about that and as
mordo warned in the first dr strange
film that bill has come due you can't
keep doing that again and again and
expect to just get away with it in
reality not to react to that and now
reality is starting to unwind by the
seams in fact it's taken the exact
visual form of what we saw in the
episode of what if episode 4 the doctor
strange episode it's melting into this
inky black nothingness and now this
trailer seems to double down on the
connections to what if by bringing in
the zombie characters from the what if
zombies episode this is much more clear
in the tv version of the spot but i'm
very certain we are left with zombie
scarlet witch who was one of these soul
survivors from those episodes she showed
back up again in the final episode of
the season it was amazing to see the
ultron centuries being the ones to
detain prisoner strange and bring him to
the illuminati that to me seems like
pretty good evidence that one of these
members of the illuminati is an
alternate version of iron man maybe from
a reality where the victory over ultron
played out differently hell maybe even
one of the members of this illuminati is
ultron infinity from the episode of what
if and that's why they have these ultron
centuries as guards so back last year at
some point they announced that writing
the latest draft of this movie was going
to be mike waldron he was the showrunner
on loki and you can totally see the
parallels in the movie that is being
presented in this trailer right a
sorcerer rascal has subverted the laws
of reality broken the multiverse in a
key way and ended up paying for that in
front of a judicial body but by doing
this reality has been screwed up so
badly that the only way he can clear his
name is by fixing what he did wrong and
so he puts together this team of
multiversal warriors including america
chavez america chavez gets a lot more
action in this trailer and yes i don't
think my eyes deceived me there did we
just see captain marvel fighting wanda
maximoff but is this brie larson carol
danvers captain marvel or a captain
marvel variant because my friends i
think monica rambo being part of
wandavision is an important step of this
journey we may be looking at an
alternate reality captain marvel in
which it is gonna be monica rambo monica
versus wanda yes we're definitely gonna
rewatch one division ahead of this and
really i just love how much this trailer
is focusing more on wanda maximoff and
what her role is going to be in the
story i think it's gonna be crucial
obviously specifically the fact that we
returned to her house in west view with
alternate versions of herself i don't
think she's fully aggrieved and moved on
from what happened in west view i think
we're all gonna need to re-watch
wandavision to really figure out what
the implications of that were but now
the house is constructed once more may
suggest that wanda has tragically tried
to reassemble this reality just to try
to live in a fictitious world where
vision is alive again we may actually be
looking at the end of the movie wanda's
no more mutants moment where she
permanently rewrites reality in a
specific way so that her sons are back
in this world and in the mcu they may
flip it so that that final wish isn't no
more mutants it's let there be mutants
let there be others like me in this
world and that's how we end up
permanently with the x-men in this
reality ladies and gentlemen we are
looking at potentially an even bigger
multiversal crossover event than what we
saw in spider-man no way home because in
addition to those sony versus realities
that were brought in the mcu now we have
every marvel title including those and
the x-men movies and deadpool and the
fantastic four and blade and everything
we've seen in the mcu all set up to come
back in this movie the doors have been
open and they can never be closed now
i'm not going to jump to any conclusions
yet and say that mephisto is gonna be
among those cameos but we do actually
have a new mephisto shirt that you can
get your hands on two designs i believe
i'm gonna have both of them on at all
times that's the only way i can praise
my lord and savior so go get your hands
on those designs at
newrockstarsmerch.com
again i'm going to break down this
trailer shot by shot a full in-depth
breakdown for everything that i missed
in this reaction that's going to come
out on the channel tomorrow don't you
worry so keep an eye out for that follow
me on instagram and twitter at vos
following rockstars and subscribing to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you